[Music]
foreign
how do I digitize text from documents
hmm so you're tired of living in the
Stone Age drowning in piles of paperwork
and business documents well buckle up
and get ready because I'm about to blow
your mind with a tech solution that'll
change your life step one get your data
in cloud storage
easy peasy step two protect your
sensitive information by integrating DLP
no more embarrassing moments step 3
stream your data into your storage
system of choice using Pub sub oh yeah
and the best part even if you're not
using Google cloud services you can
still call this API and make your life
easier so there you have it
say goodbye to piles of paperwork and
hello to searchable digitized data your
life just got a lot easier